did Mr Beast go too far with this
Lamborghini stunt Mr Beast is not only
known as the most subscribed YouTuber
but also for his philanthropic axe he
planted millions of trees cleaned up
tons of ocean plastic and has donated
Millions to charity but not all of his
actions please viewers in a recent video
he detonated tons of explosives and
tipped a Lamborghini into the world's
largest Shredder which got some viewers
concerned while many fans didn't mind
other viewers were not happy about the
environmental impact of those explosions
because they release hazardous materials
and harm air quality the Lamborghini
stunt also raised eyebrows because even
though it was decommissioned people
asked why not recycle it instead of
shredding it but despite the negative
feedback one redditor defended Mr B
saying the actions of a YouTube channel
are nothing compared to the
institutional waste of Corporations so
are you also asking